il n'y aura bientôt plus de voitures sur
la promenade mendès france
une allée permettra aux piétons et aux
vélos de circuler tranquillement en bord
de loire
à quelques mètres de là l'esplanade
valin sera aussi réaménager des travaux
financés en partie grâce à ce programme
action coeur de ville des aides de
l'état qui bénéficie également aux
commerces et il y a des besoins
on peut tout trouver en sachant
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'alimentaire en
fait qui va qui va nous manquer un petit
peu même si aujourd'hui donc on
on a des ouvertures dans l'alimentaire
mais on attend le carré saint vincent où
il y aura donc une offre majoritairement
alimentaire dans ce centre la
dynamisation commerciale ne suffit pas
pour un centre-ville animé il faut aussi
permettre aux gens aux familles de vivre
sur place
or dans le coeur de la ville beaucoup
d'appartements sont vacants depuis
longtemps la partie la plus complexe de
la question du logement
la reconquête de logement parce que nous
sommes devant des propriétaire ou
copropriétaire difficilement joignables
pour certains qui n'habite plus le
territoire devant certains bâtiments qui
se dégradent donc c'est le pour moi le
sujet le plus complexe mais nous
avançons nous avançons je crois sur une
dynamique qui va s'engager surtout dans
l'année qui vient changer le visage d'un
centre ville ça prend du temps c'est
aussi ce que nous dit le maire de
romorantin lanthenay qui mise sur les
commerces la ville a permis récemment à
un primeur et un fleuriste de
s'installer en plein centre j'ai loué un
endroit clé de la rue georges clemenceau
et il a fallu que la ville réhabilite
les locaux donc investi cent mille euros
et qu'ensuite on lui propose un loyer
moins deux mois au niveau que ceux du
l'hyper centre pour justement créer un
effet vertueux une mercerie doit aussi
rouvrir bientôt et le pressing est en
travaux alors est-ce que ça suffit pour
les habitants les avis sont partagés
quand nous sommes arrivés cette ville
assez dynamique
j'ai l'impression que ça perd de plus en
plus de vigueur en fin de compte on fait
ses courses a vraiment en moi je
m'habille à romorantin j'ai mes chances
à romorantin sans problème
il ya beaucoup de commerces qui ferment
beaucoup de gens qui sont partis
ailleurs
ce qui montre le travail des pays m'a
trahie et amis
la situation est particulière en effet
entre la crue de 2016 la fin de matra et
cette année la crise sanitaire difficile
de soutenir l'activité dans la ville